everything chrome coronavirus a social
distancing doesn't have Courtney Cox
down yep that's her right there a busted
a move on tick-tock that's Court having
a little fun with the why is everything
chrome challenged she posted her moves
to tick-tock on Saturday alongside a
hilarious caption that read quote could
this be white cocoa and Johnny are
socially distancing themselves from me
hashtag bored hashtag quarantine of
course cocoa is her 15 year old daughter
and Johnny McDaid is her longtime beau
Courtney's celeb pals flooded the
comment section with praise selma Blair
Allison Janney and Reese Witherspoon
loved watching port shake it but there
was one very confused fan Kourtney's
friends co-star Matthew Perry who asked
tight Lenny what the hell just happened
you said that was sexy but it's hardly
the first time the friends star has
pulled a Monica on social media core and
Coco showed off their moves together and
it gave everyone major friends vibes
[Music]
whether it's tik-tok dances or musical
duets safe to say Courtney is crush in
social media
[Music]